ok today we're going to learn about
energy efficiency we're going to see
what energy efficiency means we're going
to apply it to a real-life example and
we're going to see how to use this
equation here so first of all what is it
what does energy efficiency actually
means what energy efficiency means is
what proportion of the energy supplied
in a particular situation is being being
transferred into a useful form now to
try make sense of this we're going to
have a look at a real-life example so a
real simple example here of just a
battery powered fan so here's just a fan
here and when you switch it on the
blades turn around and it cools it blows
air to cool you down ok so first of all
we need to think about the energy
transfers that are going on in here so
the energy that it starts off with is it
starts off with energy in the chemical
store because we have energy stored in
the batteries now the useful energy
transfer that we're getting is we're
converting energy from the kinetic of
chemical store to the kinetic store
so the kinetic remember means movement
however this is not the only energy
transfer that's happening here we also
have an unwanted energy transfer as well
because we are also transferring energy
into the thermal storm now the reason
for that is whenever we have work which
is done mechanically like the spinning
of these blades
we have frictional forces and those
frictional forces causes a transfer to
the thermal store so the energy is
dissipated to the surroundings so here
we have energy being converted to the
thermal store now in this particular
context it's not useful to have energy
lost the thermal store it would be
preferable be preferential to have all
of that energy converted from the
chemical store to the Kinect
six door but like I said whenever we've
got these moving parts and these
frictional forces we have energy which
is wasted to the thermal storm so now we
need to have a look at how this
particular example relates to this
equation here because efficiency is the
useful energy transferred divided by the
total energy supplied so let's see what
that means now let's imagine that within
this battery we're supplying this fan
with eight thousand joules of energy so
that is the total energy which is being
supplied to this battery-powered fan now
let's imagine that firm will store let's
imagine that about let's imagine 2,000
joules of energy is converted to is it's
basically transferred to the thermal
store so what we're going to do now is
with this information we've got to
figure out what is the efficiency of
this battery-powered fan so the way that
we do it is like this first of all we
need to figure out the useful energy
which has been transferred so if we have
a quick look we can see that we were
supplied with eight thousand joules so
that was my initial energy 2000 of which
has been converted to a transfer to the
thermal store so all I need to do to
find a useful energy using the idea of
conservation of energy
so no energy is lost sorry no energy is
created or destroyed it's just to
convert it from one form to another if
that huh if that is how much it converts
from thermal store the rest of it must
be useful energy ie converted to the
kinetic store so 6,000 joules is useful
so now I've got that information all I
need to do is put it into this equation
so my efficiency is nice and simply the
useful energy transferred now I've
worked on my useful energy transferred
here this is the amount of energy that
gets converted to the kinetic store
which is 6,000
and I need to divide that by the total
energy supplied which is 8,000 joules
remember whenever waiting with energy
the units are always joules so the
answer to this is I did this on a
calculator previously but please always
use a calculator is 0.75 now it's
absolutely fine to you to leave this as
a decimal if you want to or if you
prefer to express it as a percentage you
just need to times it by a hundred so
either of these answers here are
perfectly acceptable answers to show the
energy efficiency of the transfers
within this electric fan the quick check
to make sure you haven't made a mistake
is these this number here should never
be near over 1 if you've left it as a
decimal and this percentage here should
never be over a hundred if you've
expressed it as a percent so that
basically is how energy efficiency works
thank you